we've seen the american motion picture  become foremost in all the world  we've seen it reflect our civilization  throughout the rest of the world  the aims and the aspirations  and the ideals of a free people  and of freedom itself  the motion picture industry has utilized  its vast resources  resources of talent and facilities  in a sincere effort to help the people  of the hemisphere  to come to know each other  dictators  those who enforce the totalitarian form  of government  think it's a dangerous thing for their  unfortunate peoples  to know that in our democracy  officers of the government are the  servants  and never  the masters of the people  thank you very much sir it's a great  thrill to me in the picture  you did called philadelphia story  thank you miss fontaine  i don't know how to express my gratitude  i don't know how it happened that i have  it in my hand but  i have  and  i'm indeed grateful  and this is the greatest moment of my  life  thank you